[Musica]
secondo voi io posso essere una risorsa
per il paese
prima di rispondere però a questa
domanda
cerchiamo di capire che cosa vuol dire
essere una risorsa per il paese
la prima cosa che ti può venire in mente
è che una persona possa essere una
risorsa per l'economia di un paese
immaginate tutte quelle persone che con
la loro attività favoriscono il
benessere economico del paese
ma le risorse di un paese non sono
soltanto economiche possono anche essere
artistiche pittori scrittori musicisti o
magari possono essere sportive oppure
possono essere culturali
cosa vuol dire magari una persona con se
stesso con il suo modo di essere
con il suo stile di vita può aiutarci a
oltrepassare i nostri limiti ad ampliare
la visione sugli altri e perché no anche
a cambiare la mentalità di un paese ma
torniamo alla domanda iniziale
allora io posso essere una risorsa per
il paese
allora non so se ve ne siete accorti ma
io sono una persona disabile lo so
eravate distratti dalla mia tra riparte
bellezza e non ve ne siete accorti
vedo la signora qui abolisce ma io lo
sono davvero ve lo giuro
io anche portato il mio pedigree quello
che ha diagnosticato a quale razza io
appartengo
eccolo qua cmt 1a è bello scritto così
sembra quasi una formula magica in
realtà sono le iniziali dei medici che
hanno scoperto questa malattia è una
malattia neuropatica colpisce i nervi e
per induzione e muscoli è ereditaria ma
tendenzialmente non è così aggressiva
c'è la mia madre
però se la guardate sembra che non abbia
nulla e invece come è stata
particolarmente aggressiva
mi sono piaciuto proprio tanto non mi ha
mai mollato
mi ha voluto plasmare come voleva avete
presente il gioco dei shanghai
ecco io credo che il mio creatore abbia
fatto la stessa cosa con le mie ossa
semmai si gioca così 41 bastoncini di
plastica li prendi le butti sul tavolo
così senza un senso logico con le mie
ossa hanno fatto così vanno buttate
sulla terra sono nato io senza un senso
logico e devo dire che in alcuni momenti
della giornata anche senza un senso
pratico ma questo è un altro discorso
vi ho convinto che sono veramente
disabile
oppure vi devo raccontare che esco
soltanto per fare del bricolage
accompagnato nella mia badante russa o
che non ho mai avuto relazioni o persone
un angelo asessuato no mi dispiace ma
sotto questo aspetto non vi posso
rassicurare e a tal proposito
vi ho portato una serie di diapositive
che mi faranno vedere nel dettaglio
tutte le posizioni che io posso
praticare con la mia compagna e ridete
partiamo ancora prima diapositiva paura
e stavo scherzando stava scherzando
stavo scherzando anche perché mi si
vorrebbero dalle tre alle quattro ore
per spiegarle tutte
sì ho capito ma allora sei o no la
risorsa per il paese e poi che cosa vuol
dire questa cosa che fa il dopo ciò ci
trovi la fidanzata o il fidanzato
no questo rischio lo lascio a voi cerco
di spiegarmi meglio un po di tempo fa
una ragazza mi scrisse max ma io che
cosa posso fare per sentirmi bella e io
gli ho risposto sentirti bella ecco
diciamo che un lob coach non aggiunge un
qualcosa alle persone casomai cerca di
tirar fuori dalle persone
quello che loro già posseggono cerca di
spronarli di tirar fuori le vostre
qualità di enfatizzare ciò che vi
distingue sapete le miei primi 30 anni
quando vivevo in una piccola cittadina
della toscana a piombino
io non ero così ero molto timido
ero molto introverso avevo il terrore
che le persone fossero condizionati dal
mi aspetto e quindi anche loro
atteggiamento nei miei confronti e
quindi ero condizionato anch'io verso di
loro
insomma era un cane che si mordeva la
coda poi ai tempi non c'era internet e
quindi praticamente la prima cosa che tu
vedevi di una persona era l'aspetto
fisico utilizzati solo gli occhi quando
è arrivato internet è cambiato tutto
e voi direte perché
perché la prima cosa che si conosceva di
una persona erano i suoi pensieri
no l'aspetto fisico non è come adesso
con con facebook che potete vedere le
foto magari come stai in costume magari
che lavoro fa magari potete vedere dove
vive e anche quello che pensa a seconda
di quello che pubblica nella sua bacheca
ai tempi non c'era tutto questo io mi
ricordo la prima chat che si chiamava ci
sei mi sembra e c'era solo nickname
quindi non so trovavi fragolina 86 che
poi poteva anche essere fragolino 86 ma
tanto non lo sapevi non c'era nulla e
iniziava a tirar fuori i tuoi pensieri
io allora mi sentivo più sicuro non
c'era il filtro del corpo
ho scoperto ben presto che le donne
hanno una caratteristica meravigliosa
allora se l'è colpite alla testa
metaforicamente parlando è tutto il
resto si trasforma passate da rospi a
principi anche senza essere baciati
e allora jolie navi le mie letture
shakespeariane i grandi classici e
quindi mi davo da fare
cioè non è che basta scrivere ciao sono
marco 30 anni e sono molto sensibile a
tutte le donne di aa2 piedi no ci si
deve dare a fare un log corse fa anche
questo cerca di spronarli mi è capitato
spesso di sentire la frase nessuno mi
vuole ma secondo me la domanda è posta
maniera errata non ti devi chiedere
perché nessuno mi vuole ma casomai
perché qualcuno debba volere proprio me
tutto va conquistato è ma io non mi
sento bella io non mi sento bello
ma scusate per voi che cosa significa
sentirsi belli
qual è il concetto di belli è quanto di
bello di bellezza è quello passato da
dai media dalle tv dalle riviste oppure
per voi
il bello in qualcosa di unico con
qualcosa di diverso dal solito
ora non voglio scomodare il detto donna
baffuta sempre piaciuta però de gustibus
c'era una ragazza una mia mica un po di
tempo fa che aveva un neo proprio qui in
mezzo alla fronte a me piaceva
moltissimo quel neo poi all'improvviso è
scomparso io pensavo fosse una cosa di
salute
e invece mi ha detto no è per estetica
estetica ma meravigliosa la rendeva un
po unica quasi indiana erano è un suo
segno di distinzione
un po come il nasone di penelope cruz e
qualcuno può dire che la l'attrice non
sia affascinante sei qualcuno potrebbe
dirlo ma anche in quel caso de gustibus
ma voi ditemi una cosa avete mai visto
disabili persone disabili in televisione
si l'avete viste persone disabili in
televisione ma per quale motivo
principalmente sono sempre due o è una
raccolta fondi per la ricerca e che va
benissimo per caricare oppure magari
perché sono eroi dello sport ma persone
disabili in televisione che non parlano
di disabilità l'avete mai visti cioè
veramente sembra che noi 24 ore su 24 si
parli soltanto di disabilità tra l'altro
mi sto rendendo conto che lo sto facendo
pure io adesso ma perdonatemi
torniamo alle pubblicità ad esempio
scusate ma è mai possibile che anche per
una pubblicità di un dentifricio ci
debba essere una donna o un uomo
perfetti non bastano i denti perfetti
tutto il corpo deve essere perfetto ma
se una pubblicità di un dentifricio la
facessi io come persona disabile quale
sarebbe il problema
e voi direte ma perché là delle fate io
vi dico e perché no magari vi aiuterebbe
un pochino ad abituare ad abituare i
vostri occhi alla diversità esempio io
qualche anno fa sono stato in un paesino
in montagna con un pulmino di quelli che
hanno il sollevatore elettrico per le
carrozzine
quando sono arrivato questi del paesino
erano 300 anime oddio è arrivato un
marziano quella la sua astronave
diciamo che quando mi hanno visto è
stata una conferma per loro però questo
è un altro discorso ma se io faccio la
stessa cosa a londra oa parigi oa roma a
roma trovarne un pulmino accessibile per
un altro discorso
nessuno mi si fila perché perché sono
abituati quello che voglio dirvi è che
se la vostra ricerca è quella di
inseguire un prototipo di bellezza
magari come uno specchio riflesso
dettato dalle pubblicità o da tutto il
resto potrebbe nascere un problema quale
problema che magari un giorno il vostro
specchio mi guarda dopo ore magari ore
passate dal chirurgo e vi chiede ma tu
chi sei
allora bisognerebbe invece enfatizzare
le vostre distinzioni le nostre
diversità non omologarle a tutto il
resto alimentare le vostre abilità
allora voi bipedi voi voi se vi sentite
abili o disabili un esempio ci sono
delle persone con disabilità tipo
autistici che hanno però delle grandi
capacità
alcuni di loro sono eccezionali in
matematica quindi magari voi sarete
molto abili ed alcune cose e molto
disabili in altre
senza offesa quello che io vi voglio
lasciare oggi se riesco è uno sguardo
nuovo degli occhi nuovi marzo e proust
diceva un vero di viaggio di scoperta
non è trovare nuove terre ma è avere
nuovi occhi magari gli occhi artistici
gli occhi di un pittore potreste mai
dire voi che un michelangelo un quadro
suo è più bello più brutto di un quadro
di picasso oggettivamente parlando no
magari potreste dare un giudizio
soggettivo ma oggettivamente parlando
entrambe le opere solo bellissime
io non amo quando mi si dice ma cos'è
come gli altri
io ti vedo che credo che sei
io amo quello che è dentro di te io amo
la tua essenza che mi sembra un pò
etereo perché su questa terra non siamo
solo e senza siamo anche presenza
preferisco sentirmi dire no ma se guarda
lo vedo benissimo che se disabile
lo vedo benissimo che sei diverso dagli
altri ma io ti amo lo stesso per quello
che sei dentro e per quello che sei
fuori
io vedo me con un picasso vedo il mio
corpo come un picasso
io quando guardo il mio corpo lo vedo
così
non è facile da guardare da comprendere
da amare ma rimane un picasso
se tu lo sai osservare se tu lo sai
comprendere se tu lo sai ma amare lo ami
perché è un picasso perché è unico come
unico è un picasso
quindi magari da domani quando uscite
per strada e vedete delle persone non mi
soffermate soltanto alla curiosità del
loro aspetto magari quella persona lì
potrebbe essere una risorsa per il paese
o magari potrebbe essere una risorsa per
voi ma in entrambi i casi comunque ne
vale la pena di conoscerla
parola di gucci grazie
[Applauso]